I'm Nikki I'm a research assistant in
the cancer genome project at the
Wellcome Trust Sanger Institute in
Cambridge my job has a lot of variation
to it that really keeps things fresh it
can be extracting DNA and RNA from
tissues and bloods it can be setting up
loads and loads of reactions on a robot
or it can be quite computer and admin
paper-based
extractions are my favorite part of the
job because you get to see the science
happening right in front of you we
normally get a tumor or a blood sample
in sometimes we get normal tissue as
well and what we do first is we break up
into small chunks so the chemicals we
use can actually get into the cells and
pull the DNA out once we've got it out
we check the what we've got and it's
good quality and then it goes off for
sequencing we use robots in the lab to
make our lives the easier the other day
I had to take it in for 1344 reactions
which if I had to do by hand would have
taken weeks but with the robots it's a
lot easier you just tell it what to do
it goes and does it for you and it only
took me a couple days in the lab where
you have a ticketing system there's two
sides to it
a digital side and paper side the
digital side normally comes first and on
that we have a big list of everything
that's going on or will go on and you
take highest priority ticket and it's
really simple just drop down and take it
then the paper side comes in you take
that through with you into the lab and
sign it off things as you're doing them
if you're not done by the end of the day
you put it in the in progress drawer and
then when it's finished you take it and
put it in the finished drawer and then
update the digital one and say
everything's done so I really like it
because it gives nice structure to the
lab and you know exactly what
going on I have degree in genetics and
my first job short after graduating was
a cold room flu research company I was
running the lab at a satellite screening
site and because it was satellite it was
quite lonely I was the only person that
was always in the lab and it got to the
point where I'm not really using my
degree genetics and sanga is kind of a
goal it's really a big deal if you do
genetics to get here so I kept trying
and trying and trying I think I had
about three interviews and eight
applications and eventually I got here I
really enjoy what I'm doing now I'm
finally a place where I'm using my
degree and it's paid off all that hard
work but I'm now at the point where I've
got to decide if I want to stay at the
same carrier working growing with them
or if I want to go back into education
get a masters get a PhD and go and get
more into the academic and research side
of things myself there either way I've
got some on my CV and that's going to
give me so many opportunities that I
wouldn't have had otherwise